The Musik Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei dieser neuen Ausgabe des Podcast-Ufo. Mir gegenüber sitzt natürlich wie immer Tizemi, Stefan, Stefan Dietze. Schön, dass du da bist. Ich freue mich. Ich freue mich ebenso sehr, gegenüber von mir sitzt nämlich der immer gut gelaunte, wohlgenährte Flotin. Oh, danke. Sorry. Nett gesagt. Nein, ich fühle mich auch wohlgenährt. Ich bin randvoll, ich bin randvoll mit Kohlensäure, ich bin Flüssigkeiten, Gas und Feststoffen. Das sieht man dir an. Gefüllt, ja wirklich, bin ich ein bisschen gebläht? Nee, gar nicht, du wirktest sehr gesund. Ach so, wohlgenährt im Sinne von energiereich. Im Sinne von energiereich, im Sinne von angriffslustig, im Sinne von, weil ich bin nicht wohlgenährt. Ich habe aus dem Gespräch der Blanke Hunger, ich habe vergessen zu essen einfach. Habe ich nicht dran gedacht. Unsere Nahrung ist natürlich auch die Kunst und die Liebe unserer Hörer, wie sie uns zugekommen ist, in Form von Felix Intro. Vielen Dank Felix, der uns geführt hat. Felix Intro 3 und das Lustige ist ja, dass wir mittlerweile fast im Postmodernen angekommen sind, also im Experimentellen. Ja. Habe ich dann Theremin rausgehört, ich weiß es nicht. Ist das das alles zu langsam voran. Mir wurden fliegende Autos versprochen, Jetpacks, Teleporter, diese Röhrensysteme in Futurama. Nichts davon ist Realität, gar nichts. Ich bin auch wirklich schockiert, dass das im Wahlkampf keine Rolle spielt. Wo ist die Jetpack-Partei? Die JPP, die einfach sagt ... Ist das nicht Volt? Es hängen überall diese Plakate von der Partei Volt, von der ich noch niemals gehört habe, herum. Und das Einzige, was ich von dem mitbekomme, ist coole Slogans im Sinne von The Future is Tomorrow, wenn ihr uns wählt, ist sogar Now und so. Obwohl ich fände besser wäre eigentlich The Future is Yesterday. Ja. Und der Wähler, also ich glaube, so eine kleinen Parteien können eigentlich nur überleben, wenn sie die Träume... Verwirrung. Und dadurch, dass sie eine leere Projektionsfläche sind, dass der Wähler denkt, ja, die machen bestimmt Jetpacks, durch die kriege ich bestimmten Haufen Jetpacks 20, 30... Eigentlich so Worthülsen entwickeln, aber machen das nicht eh alle. Aber wo jeder sich sozusagen selber verwirklicht fühlt. Also wo jeder das liest, aber es ist wie so ein Horoskop, es passt irgendwie auf jeden.
Und man denkt, ja, die setzen genau das um, was ich will, fliegende Autos.
Jetzt ist nur die Frage, was ist deren Slogan, dass alle Leute, die fliegende Autos wollen, rein interpretieren fliegende Autos.
Es muss schon noch verwirrend genug sein, dass man selber die Denkanstrengungen macht, wenn man einfach sagt, sichere Arbeit für alle.
The future was tomorrow vielleicht.
The future has been
tomorrow.
Finde ich nicht schlecht. Und erst mal
dann ein Fragezeichen. Und erst mal dann,
ja vielleicht meinen sie, also in der Zeit, wo man
dann davor stehen bleibt und Gedanken hat
und sich Gedanken zu dem Satz macht,
interpretiert man ja vielleicht schon
irgendwas rein in diese Partei und sieht sich ja schon
irgendwie damit connected. Also man hat ja schon irgendwie so ein Event kreiert, dadurch, dass so so Grüppchen stehen bleiben vor diesem Plakat und darüber nachdenken. Ja, das stimmt. Aber leider keine Möglichkeit, Jetpack-Partei ist nicht über die Prozenthürde gekommen. Wobei ich gestern dachte, the future is now, weil ich meine Roller sind mittlerweile überall angekommen, diese kleinen E-Scooter sind überall da, jeder kennt sie. Die die so auf der Strasse kriechen und nicht fliegen können. Still auf der Strasse. Lächerlich. Ja, aber das ist mittlerweile gehört zum Strassenbild dazu, vor ein paar Jahren war es noch nicht so. Gestern stand ich am Fenster abends, wie ich es immer mache, noch einmal so kontemplativ rauszugucken, gern Horizont und mir diese Gedanken, das wird mir alles irgendwann an mir gehören, bla bla bla bla. Ich stehe dann da und wirklich komplett leere Strasse und plötzlich höre ich nur so ein das Future Geräusch, dieses ja, ja, einen kleinen Jungen auf dem Roller. Und wenn der kleine Junge draufsteht und nicht grosse, erwachsene Menschen, dann hört es sich noch an wie so ein Future Schwebegeräusch ein bisschen. Und es klang wirklich einfach nach diesem elektrischen Future-Geräusch, was so Glider und so aus Blade Runner bekommen haben in den 90ern., aber ich habe ein paar unangefragte Sprachnachrichten geschickt. So tritt man ja generell mit Leuten in Kontakt, die man nicht kennt.
Erst mal eine drei-minütige Sprachnachricht.
Drei-minütige Sprachnachricht, ohne dass man sich davor kennt und also falls Doktor Musk Zeit hat, das zu öffnen, bin ich dabei. Aber akustisch sind wir in der Zukunft angekommen.
Ja, da sind wir zu weit, finde ich. Also die Akustiker hätten sich mal ein bisschen zurücknehmen müssen vielleicht, weil da sind wir jetzt mittlerweile zu weit. Das ist schon so futuristisch geworden, dass alles andere nicht mithalten konnte. Beziehungsweise haben die ein Tempo vorgelegt, was eigentlich richtig gewesen wäre, alle anderen können nicht mitmachen. Ist jemand eigentlich mal auf zwei Rollern gleichzeitig gefahren? So einen Fuss auf einem pro Roller? Ja.imässig? Wird ständig gemacht. Was ist der Rekord für die meisten Roller, die ein Mensch gefahren hat? Längst liegend, entspannt in dieser Cäsar-Position liegend, mit Weintrauben in der rechten und schön über sieben Roller hinweggelegt und damit einfach mal zur Klassenfahrt auftauchen. Und die Herren und Damen von Guinness so, ich habe wieder einen fucking Roller-Rekord. Wenn ich noch, ich schwöre dir, wenn ich noch einen Roller-Rekord angeboten bekomme heute, wenn dieses rote, grosse, rote Telefon klingelt vor mir noch einmal. Doch, du bist dran, du bist heute wieder dran. Nee, ich sag dir immer, wenn es ein Roller, dann kündige ich, dann war es das. Dann war es das mit mir und Guinness World Records. Wir wissen nicht, was kommt. Wir warten noch einfach mal, was der nächste Anrufer macht. Ganz ehrlich, wir haben ein... Nächstes Mal bist du wieder ein. Guinness World Records Buch 2021. Sprechen wir mit Stefan Dietze. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Ja, hallo, guten Tag, ich bin der Felix aus Neureuthbach. Hallo, Felix aus Neureuthbach. Und ich habe eine Idee für einen Guinness-Buch-Weltrekord, der Rekorde-Buch-Weltrekord. Da seid ihr genau richtig. Super. Wann können Sie denn vorbeikommen? Um was geht es denn, Felix? Kennen Sie diese mietbaren Elektrorolle? Nein! Felix, nein! Wir haben keinen Bock mehr auf diese Roller. Ihr Jugendlichen, ihr müsst doch mal andere Sachen noch machen. Euer Leben besteht nicht nur daraus, von A nach B zu kommen, um bei jedem Weg so um die 3,79 Euro zu bezahlen für einen fucking Elektroroller. Sucht euch andere Schwerpunkte. Wir haben das ganze Buch voll mit
scheiß E-Rollerkack.
Wie viele kann ich auf einer Hand
balancieren, wie viele kann ich damit jonglieren,
wie viele kann ich in den fucking reinwerfen pro Nacht.
Okay, ich esse 60 Chicken
McNuggets in einer Minute. So.
Bis gleich.
78 musst du essen.
Wie lange dauert es, bis
Sie hier sind?
Neureuthbach, hast du gesagt? Ja. Zehn Minuten. Ins Guinness-Mobil. Ins schnellste Fahrzeug der Welt. Ja, das stimmt eigentlich, weil eigentlich müsste Guinness, eigentlich könnte Guinness so eine Art Superbösewicht sein. Weil immer wenn die irgendwo hingehen und sagen, ah, du hast das schnellste Auto der Welt, kaufe ich, oh, du hast den Pogostick, mit dem man am höchsten springen kann, kaufe ich. Ja, oder nicht kaufen, sondern nehme ich dir weg. Ja, genau, nehme ich. Stimmt mal vor, das sind so große Schlägertypen mit Waffen. Ja. Und immer wenn die zu so richtig coolen Sachen kommen, sagen die einfach, gib mir das fliegende Auto. Ich habe die längste Schlange der Welt gefunden. Nehme ich mit? Nehme ich mit? Die fliegste Schlange der Welt. Ich habe mit an die längste Schlange der Welt gezogen. Dann machen die Knoten in die Schlange und knoten die Schlange an dem Hubschrauber fest. Aber wer, angenommen jetzt, ich habe das schnellste Fahrzeug der Welt erfunden, zu Wasser oder zu Luft, zu lüften. Ja. Dann ich die an und sage, ich will es gerne eintragen lassen, in jenes World Records Buch 2021. Ja, lass mich mal fahren. Drei, genau, und dann nehmen die es mir weg. Nee, also um es zu testen, müsste ich halt selber ansteuern. Nee, aber Sie wissen jetzt gar nicht, wie man das fährt. Naja, das ist ein Lenkrad und da ist ein Pedal, das kriege ich schon hin. Ja, stimmt, das ist wirklichord müssten wir leider auch selber Hand anlegen. Aber ich komme jetzt zurück, ich mache einmal die Runde. Sie haben gesagt, wie viel kmh, ist das schnell? 8.000. 8.000, ja. Dann wollen wir einmal die Runde. Das ist ja schneller, wenn ich geradeaus fahre, oder? Dann komme ich ja wieder bei Ihnen an. Sie können quasi einmal geradeaus, dann müssen Sie aber die Rotation ein bisschen mitnehmen. Aber ja, Sie haben recht, es ist sehr intuitiv und dann kommen sie einfach wieder hier an, okay?
Alles klar, gut, dann... Aber bitte nicht,
machen sie einen grossen Bogen um Japan, weil die haben so weirde Luftschutz... Ja, mit Zoll,
ich weiß nicht, fangen sie nicht an,
aber... Wissen sie, ne, weil die haben ja schon
mal einmal mich gewarnt, dass sie mich abschießen,
aber ne, solange sie von Japan wegbleiben
und so... Kein Problem, kein Problem.
Alles klar. Gut, dann bin ich gleich
wieder da. Ich glaube, der kommt nicht wieder. Aber ist das nicht ein guter Bösewicht? Guinness Man? Guinness Man, der einfach die besten, per Definition die besten Gentschens der Welt hat. Bester Bösewicht der Welt, ist stimmt, der hat den besten Bösewicht der Welt rekrutiert, der ist eigentlich nur so ein Beamter. Aber du merkst auch, dass der Tisch knatscht. Ja, der Tisch knatscht. Warum unternimmst du nichts dagegen und gehst ein bisschen weg vom Tisch? Weil ich hier eingeklemmt bin zwischen zwei Tischen. Weil mir gefällt, ich mag Wobbly Tables auch nicht und knatschende Dinge, aber man kann ja zumindest was dagegen unternehmen und nicht mehr rumwobbeln. Jetzt tut mir leid, ich muss mich bewegen. Ich bin voller Gas und voller Essen. Ich bin wohlgenährt, Stefan. Du bist wohlgenährt. Ich habe Verdauungsarbeit. Mein Magen macht gerade was ganz anderes. Der verdaut die ganze Zeit. Das macht so einen Unterschied. Man ist müder, wenn man viel isst, weil der Magen verdaut. Ist das richtig? Ja, aber ich glaube, wenn man schläft, verdaut er auch nicht. Dann macht er auch Pause. Dann lässt er auch Pause. Der lässt ja alles stehen und liegen. Der lässt alles stehen und liegen, aber das Gehirn verbraucht ja auch irgendwie 98 Prozent der Energie des Tages oder whatever. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich, sagen wir mal, verdaue, aber nicht nachdenke, dann bin ich nicht müde, weil nur mein Bauch die ganze Arbeit macht? Nee. Ja. Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Aber die müssen ja eigentlich, also angenommen, du isst so ein Snickers und es ist halb verdaut und dann gehst du schlafen und dann lassen die alles stehen und liegen. Die Erdnuss, die sie gerade in der Hand hatten, legen sie wieder weg und gehen ins Bett. Aber was heißt halb verdaut? Also von aussen nach innen oder so in der Mitte einmal so das Snickers so klar durch? Ich glaube einmal Querschnitt. Ich glaube, die holen erst das Karamell raus, einfach weil es am leckersten ist. Und weil es abgebaut wird. Weil man dann mehr Power hat, um den Rest abzubauen. Man muss sagen, lass uns erstmal den Zucker abbauen, um dann genug Kraft zu haben für den Rest. Dann sind wir richtig wild, können wir richtig viel abbauen. Warum sind Tabletten, die man schluckt, oft in diesen Kapseln? Was sind das für Kapseln und ist es dafür da, dass es sozusagen erst mal im Magen ankommt und dann wird diese Kapsel angegriffen? Ja, aber wenn es sich im Mund auflöst, dann hast du dann hast du deine Antiverdauungsmedizin im Mund, das ist auch nicht gut. Dann musst du es runterschlucken. Du fragst dich. Da wird doch eh über die Schleimhäute aufgenommen. Und vielleicht schmeckt das auch scheußlich. Vielleicht ist es so eine Art Hüttel, weil der Magen schmeckt ja nicht.
Ist es eine Schmeckt-Scheußlich-Schale?
Ich glaube, das ist eine SSS. Ich glaube, du hast, weil der Magen schmeckt ja nichts. Das heißt, du kannst ja alles, was du in diese Schalen einbaust. Eigentlich müsste man diese Schalen frei verkaufen. Dass wenn das Kind sagt, ich will mein Brokkoli nicht essen, der schmeckt scheußlich, dann packt man die in so eine... Schmeckt-Scheußlich-Schale. Schmeckt-Scheußlich-Schale. Und schnibbelt das Brokkoli ganz klein. Das geschnibbelte Brokkoli schmeckt scheußlich-Schale. Und dann kriegt das Kind halt so 20 neutral schmeckende Tabletten mit einem Löffel. Und das geht dann halt erst im Magen auf. Das heißt, du bist eher dafür, dein Kind so zwangszuernähern, wenn nötig, mit so einer Infusion, als ihm langfristig dem Geschmack von Brokkoli näher zu bringen. Korrekt. Du würdest auch besser kochen, vielleicht schmeckt es ihm dann. Ihr oder ihr. Ja, ach so, Moment mal, du sagst gerade, wenn Brokkoli den Kindern nicht schmeckt, ist das eine Kritik an der Kochfertigkeit der Eltern? Ja, genau. Ich glaube, das liegt langfristig, also es liegt eigentlich an den Eltern. Das heißt, wenn das Kind das Brokkoli nicht essen will, kannst du einfach sagen, nee, ich finde, du hast halt einfach nicht gut gekocht.
Meine Mutter sagt bis heute, ich mag
keine Spaghetti, was nicht stimmt.
Ich mag ihre Spaghetti nicht, aber das kann
man ja nicht sagen.
Verstehst du? Was kann man denn bei Spaghetti
falsch machen? Die sind
zu lang, oder was? Die macht die immer so
vier, fünf Meter lang. Die sind wirklich lang.
Die serviert Spaghetti und es ist
eine Spaghetti. Und ich weiß nicht, wo ich anfangen soll und wo ich aufhören soll. Ich habe viele Fragen. Find man den Anfang. Ich weiß nicht, wo ich anfangen soll. Ich weiß nicht, wie das produziert wird. Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, es liegt an den Eltern, wenn Kinder Dinge nicht mögen, liegt es an den Eltern. Spargel schmeckt ja lecker, wenn genug Soße Hollandaise da ist. Ja, ja.
Ne?
Ja, ja, ich verstehe schon.
Rosenkohl, verstehe ich schon, warum man es nicht mag.
Aber auch hier, Soße Hollandaise.
Oder halt diese Tablette, ich finde das keine schlechte Idee. Du kannst ja dann auch so lustige Bärchenmotive machen, halt in dieser Tablettenhöhle.
Da kommen dann die Rotkohl rein, schlucken, kein Geschmack.
Und im Magen, die kümmern sich drum. Wann wurden Bärchen eigentlich süss? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Der erste Kontakt zu Bären war doch nicht ah, niedlich, guck mal, die essen Honig und haben sind laut und tappt sich rum. Hilfe, Hilfe, mein Bein, Hilfe, ich sterbe. Hilfe, der greisst mir gerade mit seinen riesen Pranken meine Lunge weg. Achtung! Wo ist meine Lunge? Hilfe, Hilfe. Wo ist meine Lunge? Schnellster Bären-Tod der Welt, at Guinness.org. So. Ja, also gute Frage, sind Bären denn flauschiger als andere vergleichbare Tiere? Also sagen wir, der Elch. Ist der Elch signifikant weniger flauschig als der Bär? Wenn ich mir so eine Elch-Streichleinheit vorstelle, ist er eher garstig-borstig. Ja, okay. Ich habe noch nicht viele Elche gesehen. Ich auch nicht. Ich folge dir da intuitiv. Aber es stimmt schon, der Bär, ich glaube, der Bär hat, ich glaube, so durch seine Unbeholfenheit. Also das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen gemein. Achtung, ich gehe jetzt hier nochmal ins DSA 4.1 Regelwerk rein. Da gibt es den Tierkrieger. Ein Krieger, der verschiedene Aspekte eines Tieres … Nicht zu wechseln mit dem Kapitel 4.0 Tierkrieg. Und auch nicht verwechseln mit drei neuen Kriegertier. Nein, es ist der Tierkrieger. Und da gibt es verschiedene Ausformungen, den Rabenkrieger, den Wolfskrieger, den Bärenkrieger. Und der Bärenkrieger hat den Nachteil tollpatschig. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Bärenkrieger und Bär? Der Bärenkrieger ist das Tier Bär. Der Bärenkrieger ist nur ein Krieger, der sich mit dem Bär identifiziert, Bärenfell trägt, Honigmark, Bienen hasst, sowas, der sich so identifiziert. Und der kriegt automatisch den Nachteil toll tollpatschig, dass er häufiger Proben nicht schafft. Und der Bärenmitspieler so, äh, sorry, warum sind wir tollpatschig? Oh, Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich die Spreit umgestoßen. Nee, ich wollte nur mal fragen, warum tollpatschig? Entschuldigung, du sitzt komplett auf dem Regelbuch. Oh, sorry. Sorry, die ganzen Figuren für heute Abend. So, und da habe ich mir auch schon beim Lesen gedacht, wie gemein, wie gemein, dass der Bären kriegt den Nachteil tollpatschig. Du bist so empathisch und einfühlsam, dass es dir leidtut, dass Bären im DSA 4.1 Regelwerk leicht beleidigt werden. Ja, weil der Wolf kriegt all die coolen Fähigkeiten. Ich kann dich beruhigen, der Bär will davon nicht viel mitbekommen. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, das prägt schon die Sicht auf Bären. Aber sind Bären, also ist das ein biologischer Fakt, dass die tollpatschiger sind als andere? Was haben denn die anderen Tiere, die anderen coolen Tiere für Nachteile? Ja, halt Nachtsicht, Rudel, Alpha-Wolf, irgendwie richtig cool, weltfremd. Nachtsicht ist Nachteil vom Wolf? Ich weiß nicht, was der Wolfskrät für Nachteil hat. Vielleicht weltfremd oder sowas, keine Ahnung. Weltfremd? Ja, vielleicht sowas in der Richtung. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Andererseits Bären, die in urbanen Umgebungen sehr gut klarkommen, mit Rollern durch die Gegend fahren. Du, es gibt einen Bär, der ist in ein Auto eingestiegen, der macht die Tür auf zu einem Auto. Gut, er reißt den ab, weil er ein fucking Idiot ist, aber er kann zumindest in urbanen Umgebungen... Aber wenn es kein Schaltungsauto ist, hätte er auch damit starten können. Kein Problem. Das ist meine Autokampagne, so leicht, dass sogar ein Bär unser Auto fahren kann. Und dann stelle einfach diesen Elch, nee, diesen, wie sagt man, Erlkönig und einen Bären in eine Halle, Schön, aber so lauter Federn an der Wand, damit, falls der Bär dann doch die Kontrolle verliert. Keine Vorurteile, nur Sicherheit. Problem ist nur so eine Schicht Federn. Es sieht sehr flauschig und sicher aus, aber es ist eine Riesenkatastrophe. Lass uns doch machen, eine Schicht Federn und eine Schicht zu Spiralmetallfedern.
Also erst die mechanischen Federn, dann die tierischen Federn.
Dann Federbälle.
Dann eine Einmenschicht Federbälle.
Federbälle.
Finde ich eine gute Idee.
Das wäre eine Bär außer Kontrolle gerät.
Aber das wäre eine Werbekampagne, die ich mir anschauen würde.
Ja, würde ich mir auch anschauen. Ich würde mir danach das Auto wahrscheinlich nicht kaufen. Wir haben ein Bären und fünf Autos. Und mit welchem Auto kann er tatsächlich fahren? Aber wäre das für dich ein Grund, ein Auto zu kaufen, weil es einfach zu fahren ist? Ja. Warum? Weil du gerade Autos zu schwierig zu fahren findest? Mir ist es zu schwer. Zu schwer? Zu viele Pedale. Zu viele Pedale, zu viele Schalter, zu viele Drücke. Drei Pedale,. Ich kriege teilweise, ich kriege die Klimaanlage nicht aus, teilweise steige ich in Auto, Carsharing, ich steige in Auto, bibberig kalt, bläst mir Tundra-Wind ins Gesicht und ich kriege es die gesamte Fahrt. Von dem Tundra-Bären, der da vor drin war. Ich kriege jetzt die gesamte Fahrt nicht hin, diesen Schneesturm zu beenden und kommt durchgefroren, klapprig, zittrig hier bei der Aufnahme an.
Mir ist eiskalt, Erkältung.
Aber wenigstens hast du die ganze Zeit den Scheibenwischer an.
Das stimmt, ja. Also das ist mir viel zu aufwendig, ist auch nicht einheitlich und gefällt mir nicht. Klimaanlagen sind immer schwierig.
Damals kriege ich das Radio nicht aus, super laut, eins live, tolles Programm, aber ein bisschen laut. Bisschen laut? Du warst das mit der Rezension zu laut bei der 1Live-Website. Ja, ich habe gesagt, super Programm, tolle Moderatorinnen, tolle Moderatoren, aber leider wahnsinnig laut. Tut mir leid. Manchmal hilft es aber, weil es gegen diesen riesen Gebläse in meinem Auto gut ankommt, als einziger Sender gut ankommt. Und ich habe irgendwie diesen weirden Beifahrer, der da Honig verlangt und manchmal laut brüllt. Und da ist es ganz gut, wenn das Radio lauter ist. Wer schreibt denn so Regelwerke? Weil ich habe das Gefühl, ein Thomas Römer, Regelwerkschreiber darf jetzt nicht, also der darf nicht weltfremd sein. Der darf nicht weltfremd minus zwei haben. Der darf nicht den Nachteil weltfremd acht haben. Weil der muss per Definition alles wissen. Weil im DSA-Regelwerk geht es ja nicht nur um weltliche Dinge, sondern um alles andere. Also nicht nur Zauberer und Elfen und Vorwolde. Das Interessante an DSA ist ja im Gegensatz zum Beispiel zu Dungeons & Dragons, ist, dass es in DSA auch ganz viele Professionen gibt, die nicht die klassischen Helden sind, sondern du kannst einfach einen Bäcker spielen. Und irgendjemand musste sich überlegen, welche Talente und Werte hat der Bäcker oder der Zuckerbäcker oder ganz normale Leute, so der Bauer einfach. Und da muss man sich überlegen, was kann der, was kann der nicht. Und das ist halt auch manchmal ein bisschen willkürlich. Aber so, das ist halt auch so. Wo fängt Patisserie an, wo hört Boulangerie auf? Das ist so ein bisschen das Klischee, dass DSA so kompliziert und detailliert ist, dass es drei verschiedene Talente gibt für verschiedene Handwerksmerkmale. Ich kann keine Vanillekipferl backen. Ich habe euch das einzige Abenteuer rausgesucht, wo man Brot backen muss. Entschuldigung, ich bin Konditor. Sorry, ich bin Konditor.
Ich mache Torten, Tarts und Quiches, wenn es hochkommt.
Und Vanillekipfeil sind genau auf der Grenze zwischen Bäcker und Konditor.
Ja, aber das finde ich, das macht es echt schwierig.
Ja.
Das ist auch meine große Angst, als ich dann auch zum Beispiel
Medellin Schwartz geschaut habe, die beiden Improvisateure auf Netflix, haben ja viele auch gesehen, wenn dann so eine Suggestion aus dem Publikum kommt, die ja erst mit dem Publikum sprechen, um dann herauszufinden, worum geht dann die ganze Folge und dann ist es halt so super special interest und in Folge zwei war es ja super special interest, sie studiert halt Jura und für jemanden, der noch nie einen Jurastudiengang vor innen gesehen hat, dann zu sagen, der ganze Abend besteht jetzt aus diesem Jurastudiengang und nach nur zwei habe ich keine Fachbegriffe mehr, ist auch nicht so einfach. Zum Glück gibt es halt genug Filme in Gerichtsserien, also amerikanische Filme, deutsche Filme selten eher, weil du nicht dieses
coole Jury-System hat. Aber als deutscher
Improvisateur würdest du dir dann sofort in so ein
amerikanisches Jury-Ding abrutschen.
Aber das ganze Publikum ja auch.
Was das beste System ist,
dass du für Entertainment-Zwecke immer
dazu strebst. Ist das so, ist das beste
System das, was für Entertainment-Zwecke das
Beste auch ist? Ja, das Unterhaltsamste
ist immer das Beste, wird sich immer durchsetzen. Die Unterhaltungsevolution,
ich glaube, die Evolution hat einen
anderen Weg genommen, nicht mehr Survivor
Vielen Dank. System das, was für Entertainment-Systeme das Beste auch ist? Ja, das Unterhaltsamste ist immer das Beste, wird sich immer durchsetzen. Die Unterhaltungsevolution,
ich glaube, die Evolution hat einen anderen Weg genommen, nicht mehr Survivor
of the fittest, sondern Survivor of the funniest.
Das heißt, die Systeme überleben
und pflanzen sich fort,
die am interessantesten, lustigsten und
Entertainment-mäßig ausschlagbarst machen. Die Entertainment-Branche
ist die mächtigste Branche der Welt.
Früher war es irgendwie Militär oder Kirche oder
irgendwie sowas, aber heutzutage, die Menschen
haben nichts zu tun, den ganzen Tag sitzen rum,
müssen unterhalten werden und geben mir meist das Geld für Unterhaltung
Vielen Dank. Wettbewerbsbranche ist die mächtigste Branche der Welt. Früher war es irgendwie Militär oder Kirche oder irgendwie sowas, aber heutzutage, die Menschen haben nichts zu tun, den ganzen Tag sitzen rum, müssen unterhalten werden und geben ihr meistens Geld für Unterhaltung aus. Das heißt, die Unterhaltungsbranche ist die treibende Kraft des 21. Jahrhunderts. Und deswegen wählen sie uns, die FDP, die Funny Dudes Party. Wir sind lustige Typen, wir hauen jeden Tag einen Gag raus, wir zeigen lustige Filme am Reichstag, wir stellen eine große Leinwand auf, kommt vorbei, habt Spaß, habt Bock. FDP. Machen wir auch nicht. FDP-Sternchen. Darauf kann sich der Richter einigen. Der Lawsuit ging offensichtlich verloren. Oder FTP, kam ja auch vielleicht, Funny Team Party. FDB. Sehr close. Und die FDP so, Leute, jetzt hört mal auf! Und wir haben so ein leicht anderes Gelb. Das ist unsere Farbe. Die Leute wählen ständig die FTP oder die FDP. Ich dachte auch die ganze Zeit, wenn jetzt so diskutiert wird über Rot, Rot, Grün, Blau, Gelb, Schwarz, so, wie gut, dass die alle andere Farben haben. Oh ja. War das von Anfang an der Plan? Hat es sich, das ist meine Frage, hat es sich organisch ergeben, weil Konkurrenten ja wahrscheinlich nicht zu den gleichen Farben tendieren? Gut, es kommt Rot auch wahrscheinlich aus dem Sozialismus eher, aber sowas wie Blau hätte es ja auch vorher schon mal geben können. Ja, das kann sein. Vielleicht gab es das auch schon mal. Aber es gibt kein Weiss. Schwarz gibt es. Nee, es gibt Grau, wo ich mir denke, Orange gibt es nicht mal. Orange war die Piratenpartei. Piratenpartei, stimmt. Und die Partei ist, was ist die Partei? Auch Rot. Weiß ich nicht genau. Aberiss fehlt noch. Und dann halt, irgendwann kommt halt auch die Goldpartei, oder? Weil wir sind ja eh als Deutschland fucking schwarz-rot-gold, es ist gelb. Nein, es ist gold. Was soll das denn heißen, Gold? Das ist eine Flagge, die soll metallisch sein, oder was, du Trottel. Nein, es ist Gold. Also muss es hundertprozentig eigentlich auch eine Goldpartei geben. Wobei, was ich kurz gut finde, ist eine Goldpartei.partei, erster Punkt auf dem Wahlprogramm, wir wollen die Flagge ändern von Schwarz-Rot-Gold in Gold-Gold-Gold. Gold-Gold-Gold. Fegt euch, wir sind Gold-Gold-Gold. Also ein großer Mittelfinger vor goldenem Hintergrund, so wehend. Ja, mit so goldenen Ringen dran. Was ich aber gut besser fände, weil es auch so ein Message beinhalten würde, wäre die silberne Partei. Die sagt automatisch, wir streben nicht nach all, wir sind genüglsamer. Obwohl wir literally ein sehr wertvolles Element genommen haben, Silber. Es gibt ja auch Gold, wir haben uns gegen Gold entschieden. Wobei wir uns einig sind, dass die Bronze-Partei ein absoluter Downer ist. Niemand sagt, Bronze ist zu viel, das ist zu viel Understatement, zu bescheiden. Bronze ist auch kein cooles Metall. Zink ist einfach weird. Fucking Quecksilber? Wo wollt ihr denn jetzt hin? Plumm bumm. Die Bleipartei finde ich aber ganz schlecht. Klingt natürlich ein bisschen aggressiv. Nee, ich finde gar nicht. Ich finde, Bleipartei klingt nach behäbig, langsam, schwerfällig. Blei sind halt auch Kugeln, Patronenkugeln, Pistolenkugeln. Stimmt, Plata eplomo. Es klingt schwerfällig, aber so konservatisch, erzrechts. Ja, das stimmt, die Bleipartei. Vielleicht können wir es auch hinkriegen, dass über die Zeiten nicht mehr Farben die Parteien beschreiben, sondern Metalle oder Städte. Oder so ein Slogan. Oder die Michigan oder sowas Irgendwie sowas anderes, dass man nicht mehr in Farben geht. Ja, sondern in Buchstaben oder so ein Slogan, finde ich auch gut. Oder Tiere halt. Das gibt es ja in Amerika, dass du den Elefanten und den Esel hast, wo man sich auch sagt, wow, wie viele coole Tiere habt ihr übersprungen, um auf Esel und Elefant zu sein. Also das ist ja wie wenn du in Deutschland sagst, die Parteien sind Früchte, würden die einen sagen, wir nehmen die Banane, wir nehmen den Apfel.
Done. Beiden besten sind sofort weg.
Aber in Amerika, dass man sagt, lass uns Esel und Elefant nehmen. Und der Esel wurde aufgerufen und der war gar nicht breit, weil er gar nicht damit gerechnet hat, auf die Bühne geholt zu werden.
Der war so wie ich in der Kirche, der nicht damit rechnet, eine Fürbitte zu bekommen, nach vorne zu müssen, so Weihnachten. Der ist gar nicht breit gewesen. Wir entscheiden uns für den Esel. Was? Am Buffet, Shrimps im Mund. Weil er dachte, er muss heute keinen öffentlichen Auftritt mehr haben, gewinnt aber diese Oscar-artige Verleihung für wichtigstes Tier im Parteien-System Sorry, sorry, drückt sich überall durch. Sorry, sorry, war nicht betrunken. Als einziger einen Hut auf. Ja, Riesenhut. Dauert ewig, während der Löwe sagt, ich wäre schon hier. Ich habe mir direkt in der ersten Reihe Platz gesucht, Adler ist hier, Wolf ist da, Bär ist. Oh Gott, da hast du den ganzen Zelt umgerissen. Aber die Gegend ist ... Ich wäre bereit, ich wäre bereit, ich wäre bereit. American Grizzly Bear. Ja, aber finde ich schlecht. Aber Obst kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen, dass man sagt Banane, Apfel, Pfirsich, irgendwie sowas Früchtiges, Tropisches. Ich meine, wir müssen in Deutschland ja eh unseren gesamten Stil ändern.
Wenn es wärmer wird, wie meinst du? Es wird wärmer, wir müssen
kurze Hose, tropisch, Bikini.
Oh, glaub mir, kurze Hose haben wir schon professioniert.
Vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
Das Stadtbild muss sich ändern, wir brauchen auch
diese Strohröcke, wir brauchen diese
Kokosnuss-BHs, all das muss jetzt
langsam auch in die traditionelle Garderobe
einfließen. Kokosnuss-BHs,
Muschel-BHs, ganz wichtig.
Dinge, die man nur aus Filmen
kennt.
Vielen Dank. auch in die traditionelle Garderobe einfließen. Kokosnuss-BHs, Muschel-BHs, ganz wichtig, Dinge, die man nur aus Filmen kennt. Dinge, die man nur aus animierten Filmen kennt. Ja, du willst auch nicht das Tier sein, das man als BH benutzt, oder? Das ist auch nicht, wo du einfach sagst, ist das Leid aus? Wenn die Muschel statt dem Esel angekommen wäre, das finde ich irgendwie noch beeindruckender. Ja, das stimmt eigentlich, Muschel ist ein verrücktes Tier. Ich habe neulich im Video geguckt, sind Viren lebendig? Und alle waren sich eigentlich immer einig, nein, ziemlich kurze Doku, nee, nee, nee. Und dann acht Minuten Werbung für Squarespace. Aber dann kam raus, es gibt mittlerweile so grosse Viren, weil das Argument vor allem darauf stützt, dass sie nicht gross genug sind, um Bewusstsein zu haben oder so lebendige Aktionen vollführen zu können. Und es gibt aber so grosse Superviren, die sind nicht besonders gefährlich. Ist das wirklich der richtige Zeitpunkt, um darüber zu reden, dass es jetzt noch riesigere Superviren gibt? Nee, es kommt ja nicht auf die Größe an. Ach so, gut. Sondern worauf kommt es da? Auf die Gefährlichkeit. Es kommt nicht auf die Größe an, sondern wie gefährlich du bist. Definier Gefährlichkeit? Tötbar. Tötbar? Nee, Tötsam. Tötsam. Gut. Okay. Und die sind lebendig oder was? Nee, auch nicht. Okay. Sorry, das wollte ich eigentlich. Sind die Riesenwiren lebendig? Nee, auch nicht. Aber gute Dokus gibt es momentan. Ich bin wieder so ein bisschen Doku-Fieber. Bob-Ross-Doku auf Netflix hab ich mir reingezogen. Und es ist sehr oft so, wenn es so neue Dokus gibt, die man gerade schaut, dann redet man da auch drüber so. Twitch-Chat irgendwie, ihr habt ihr gerade die Bob-Ross-Doku gesehen und alle reden drüber so. Das ist so, da kann Netflix sagen, ab jetzt will ich, dass Leute beim Kaffeetrinken mit den Schwiegereltern jetzt reden über Bob Ross. Aber ist es nicht immer, was für ein Mega-Arschloch das war? Eigentlich schon. Deswegen dachte ich mir, eine Doku über Bob Ross ist eine Herausforderung, weil du kriegst den nicht böse, du kriegst den nicht schlecht. Dann kannst du sagen, ja, der hat seine Frau betrogen. Ja, so what, Bob Ross. Was denkt die Frau? Ja, das ist wie wenn du eine Doku machst über den Weihnachtsmann und du sagst, ja, mein Gott, der hat seinen Kontakt zu seinem Sohn abgebrochen. So what, der beschenkt alle Kinder der Welt. Wobei, da will ich die versprechen. Ich glaube, der Weihnachtsmann hat mittlerweile einen sehr, sehr schlechten Ruf.
Wirklich? Ja, so als Kapitalismus.
Habe ich da ein paar Skandale verpasst? Ja, ich glaube schon.
Echt? Also zum einen gab es da diese Unschöne-MeToo-Geschichte,
zum anderen ist halt
der Weihnachtsmann ja so ein bisschen
so auch Vorreiter, Kapitalismus,
unbeschönliches
Konsumverhalten. Ja, aber der schenkt ja die Sachen her.
Moment, warum ist das denn Konsum? Der schenkt das doch her.
Ja, aber der treibt das ja an und die Eltern,
der arbeitet auch mit den Eltern unter einer Decke.
Auch im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes,
deswegen gab es halt
das Schammer.
Das lasse ich nicht zu,
dass du sagst, der arbeitet mit den Eltern zusammen.
Das ist widerlegt worden,
er hat gesagt, das macht er nicht
und ich glaube ihm. Dieses eine Interview bei Oprah führt jetzt für mich nicht dazu, dass man ihm wieder glauben kann, aber okay, vielleicht bin ich da zu streng. Aber das sind so die Sachen, und Bob Ross hat die Doku jetzt nicht geschafft, Bob Ross mir mal nicht zu machen. Aber hat sich das denn versucht? Er hat es versucht, ja, aber, naja, auch nicht so, kannst ja nicht so viel Schlimmes machen, aber ist halt trotzdem ein toller Typ. Was Was ich mir aber dachte ist, also wenn ich Netflix wäre, du kannst ja tatsächlich die Doku einfach ändern. Und was ich machen würde, ich würde ungefähr fünf verschiedene Bob-Ross-Dokus produzieren lassen. Einmal geht es um Drogenproblemen, einmal geht es um Hat die Frau betrogen, einmal geht es um Hat den Sohn, er hat die Bilder gar nicht selber gemalt, sondern seinen Sohn. David. Hältst du irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Fünf verschiedene Versionen und die lädt man alle hoch, aber wenn du dann die Doku anguckst, kriegst du zufällig eine von den fünf. Sodass es sein kann, dass du mit deinem Kollegen redest auf der Arbeit und hast hier die Bob-Ross-Docke gesehen, ja krass, oder? Mit diesen ganzen Drogen und alles? Und der andere sagt, was?
Nein, der Sohn war Bob Ross.
Es gab diesen aufwendigen Trick,
dass er immer quasi, er hat in die Kamera
gesprochen, noch selbst, und dann beim
Umdrehen war es dann plötzlich ein anderer Arm.
Und man sieht auch, dass es eine Perücke ist.
Nein, ich meine diese Drogen, weil es hieß doch, dass der nur so gut drauf ist,
weil er irgendwie immer vor jeder Aufzeichnung
Drogen genommen hat. Bei mir ging es vor allem um die Perücke.
Der dritte,
der Praktikant. Und einfach um
Vielen Dank. weil es hieß doch, dass der nur so gut drauf ist, weil der irgendwie immer vor jeder Aufzeichnung Drogen genommen hat. Bei mir ging es vor allem um die Perücke. Der dritte, der Praktikant. Und einfach um maximale Verwirrung im Land zu stiften, dass Leute mit einer reden und einfach, was, ich komme überhaupt nicht mit, weil Leute lieben es ja über was zu reden, was sie alle gesehen haben und alle können mitreden, und da einfach mal den schönen Bein stellen und für Verwirrung sorgen. Das würde ich machen. Ja, was mich auch irritiert, du kannst ja Dinge ändern. Also die haben ja Dateien Zugriff gerade. Das sind ja wie, wenn du das anklickst jetzt, greifst du auf eine Datei zu, die können ja verändert werden. Ja. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt in fünf, ich fände es cool, wenn sich Dinge weiterentwickeln Ach so. Oder halt verändern oder die mal aus Spaß, was so eine, was ich ja die ganze Zeit denke, wenn die Simpsons gefeiert werden für eine krasse Vorhersage und oh, die Simpsons haben Trump vorhergesagt oder sowas.
Wer sagt denn, dass die nicht einfach die Datei von der Folge geändert haben?
Weißt du, also, dass man dann, ich finde es total lustig, wenn die jetzt irgendwie eine Doku rausbringen, die quasi vielleicht Corona oder sowas komplett vorhersagt, den ganzen Verlauf, und das aber dann zurückdatiert hochladen. Und dann kriegt man das an, oh diese Doku Contagious aus dem Jahre 1994, kriege ich mal an und dann what? Die haben genau die Lotte-Zahlen vorhergesagt und in welchem Jahr
Bruno Mars auf Platz 1 ist. Wie konnten die das
machen in diesem Film?
Ja, genau, vielleicht können die ja auch auf diesem Weg,
haben die ja dann vielleicht das Vertrauen
von so einer sehr schwierigen Verschwörungstheoretiker-Gruppe
und können dann die debanken.
Die können die debanken.
Oder sie rebanken sie, indem sie sozusagen sagen, das war alles von langer Hand geplant. Weil wenn du sagst, Bruno Mars wurde vorhergesagt, dann ist ja die Frage, geht das überhaupt mit den richtigen Dingen zu? Genau. Du befeuerst ja dann eher Verschwörungstheoretiker. Ja, das stimmt auch. Aber diese sehr ungefährliche Bruno Mars-Verstörungstheorie, die erträgt man ja, glaube ich jetzt.
Ja, es gibt Familien, die leiden, hauptsächlich die Familie Mars.
Es gibt eine Familie Mars, die leidet, alle anderen Planeten sind safe.
So, aber das finde ich okay, das ist ein geringere Übel als jetzt diese ganzen Flat-Earth-Raw.
Gibt es Leute, die den Vornamen Sailor haben und Sailor Mars, die sich da einheiraten können, die einfach heißen wie Sailor Mars? Das war auch geil. Ich kenne Sailor Moon. Es gibt ja alle Planeten. Es gab ja Sailor Mars, Sailor Venus, Sailor Pluto. Sailor wie? Sie ist leider raus. Die ungeliebte Schwester. Jemanden mega Leben hat, by the way. Sailor V. May I say, sie hat das beste Leben. Sailor V war richtig coole Socke, hat alles gemacht, hat ein mega Leben. Sailor V? Aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob Sailor Pluto gab. Ich glaube nicht. Weil da müssen sie nämlich auch nochmal die gesamte Serie umschreiben und sagen, Sailor Pluto, du bist raus. Warum? Du bist ein Zwergplanet, kein echter Planet. Ja, aber kann ich nicht doch gegen das Böse kämpfen? Nein, du kannst gar nichts, du bist klein und unbedeutend. Wir wollen dich nicht dabei haben, Sailor Pluto. Schwächling. Und dann kommt Sailor V und sagt, weißt du was, Pluto? Wir machen uns ein schönes Leben ohne diese ganzen weirden Sailors. Wir gehen erst mal schön Crêpes essen. Oder? Wäre das was? Wäre das was? Und Sailor Pluto so. Ja, okay. War das damals auch schon so, als ich das als Kind gesehen habe? Irgendwie kommt mir das ganz unbekannt vor. Hat Netflix das nachverändert. Ja, kann auch sein. Aber das würde ich machen. Aber das ist eigentlich eine geile Idee, wenn du eine Doku hast, die zehn Jahre alt ist, wo mittlerweile der Mordfall gelöst ist, anstatt die Doku neu zu drehen, kannst du einfach hinten dranhängen. Texttafel, Leute, der Mord ist jetzt gelöst, ciao. Ja, aber brich zum Teil zwei raus. Aber dann muss man ja wieder irgendwie 90 Minuten füllen. Ich verstehe immer, was du meinst. Einfach Dinge verändern. Oder jetzt mit dem Game of Thrones Finale waren viele nicht zufrieden. Ich habe es noch nicht gesehen, aber viele sagen, es war nicht gut, unbefriedigend, gefällt uns nicht. Jetzt einfach quasi das zu verändern, mal so heimlich stimmendweise. Ja, dass du dann nochmal so Voice-Over drüber machst oder ganz viele Texttafeln, Daenerys dreht doch noch um, spuckt kein Feuer und geht nach Hause. Oder geht noch mal zu diesen Reiterleuten hin. Und dann kommt der Rabe und sagt, was für ein Ritt. Ende. Was für eine grosse Spende. To not be continued. Es hätte er die ganze Zeit schon so einen Catchphrase gehabt, der aber nie vorkam. Ja genau, der Catchphrase von dem, den Rame habe ich überhaupt nicht gecheckt, ich habe die Hälfte von dieser Serie nicht gecheckt. Was für eine grosse, und dann ist das Ende, und man nimmt die ganze Zeit so, Rabe, es kam noch nie vor. Warum spricht der am Ende so, als wäre das ein Callback-Gag zu irgendwas, was schon mal gesagt wurde? Ja, finde ich schlecht. Aber gute Figur. Ich glaube, man müsste eh Serien neu denken und zu sagen, du machst eine Serie. Warte, ich schreibe mit, ich schreibe mit. Ja, nimm eine neue Serie und nimm die besten Figuren aus allen anderen Serien. Gib mir Jerry Seinfeld, den Joker, Sailor V
und den dreiäugigen Raben aus
Game of Thrones, pack die in eine WG,
geiles Bassintro, verrückter
Nachbar, Moe Sislak,
let's go. Du hast im Kern Seinfeld
gepitcht.
Weil Moe Sislak ist ein bisschen Kramer.
Oh, das weiß ich nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe Drown Together gepitcht, ein bisschen, aber die sind ja auch in so einer Show. Ja, gut. Die Entertainment-Branche, ich sag's dir, die Entertainment-Evolution, die können alles. Ja, ich sehe deinen Punkt auch genau. Also ich glaube auch, das ist eine steile These jetzt vielleicht, aber ich glaube, Nordkorea, der Westen, der gemeine Westen duldet Nordkorea nur, weil es halt irgendwie auch ein bisschen unterhaltsam ist.
Ja, absolut.
So die Dokus werden geschaut, werden gemocht.
Und alle fragen sich, wohin geht das noch? Es ist absurd, es ist auch ein spannendes, also jetzt mal ganz blöde gesagt, irgendwie gucken, was passiert da jetzt noch. Ja. So, wie so ein Mikrokosmos, wo man auch mal interessant draufguckt und denkt, ah krass.
Und ab und zu so eine Maulwurf-Doku zu haben, um zu sehen, was für weirden Konferenzsälen mit blinkenden Lichtern die Entscheidungen treffen, das ist alles sehr merkwürdig und man will auch irgendwie wissen, in welche Richtung das jetzt noch geht. Ja, es ist irgendwie so eine Gegenkultur, die so komplett ihr eigenes Ding machen und wo man auch vielleicht macht wie in so einer kleinen Petrischale, mal guckt, was passiert, wohin die... Vielleicht kommen die auch auf eine gute Idee. Ja, vielleicht kommen die auf eine gute Idee, vielleicht haben die eine richtig geile neue Frisur, die wir im Westen noch gar nicht kennen. Bislang nicht. Bislang nicht. Strong no. Aber es kann ja sein, dass sich daraus nochmal was ergibt, dass die sagt, mit einer neuen Generation, einem neuen Diktator sagen, neue Frisur. Und dann, wo wir im Westen sagen, wow, Politik finde ich nicht so gut, aber die Frisur ist mega geil. Ja, genau wie man manchmal ja Menschen von Geburt an in so Räume sperrt, damit die erst gar nicht von der Welt quasi in irgendeine Richtung geprimed werden und auf ganz neue Ideen kommen. Genau, so diese alte Frage, was ist, wenn du einen Menschen mit einer Gitarre in den Raum sperrst, wird der früher oder später auf Angels kommen? Wird der irgendwann Angels komponieren oder Beethovens Fünfte?
Selbstständig.
Also ist das sozusagen angelegt in der Menschheit, Bruno Mars, verschiedene Leave the Door Open, verschiedene Hits?
Oder braucht es diese Genies in der Menschheitsgeschichte, die die entwickeln?
Oder würde früher oder später eh jemand E ist gleich im C-Quadrat entwickeln?
Und deswegen haben wir sie eingesperrt und sie haben nichts gemacht. Weißt du, was ich glaube? Wir sind das Experiment. Wir beide. Nee, die Welt. Die Erde. Ah, wir sind die Petrischale. Jede Zivilisation stellt sich an irgendeinem Punkt die Frage, wie entsteht Leben, ist Leben zwangsläufig irgendwann am Start und so. Das heißt, ich glaube, immer werden Zivilisationen dahinstreben, Leben zu kreieren oder zumindest einen Raum zu schaffen, in dem Leben kreiert werden könnte oder so. Und dann findet jede Zivilisation raus, ah, okay, wir sind auch nur ein Experiment. Jede Zivilisation findet raus, ah, wir sind eine Matruschka. Ah, okay. Wir sind ja auch so entstanden, weil die Situation vor uns wissen wollte, können sie Leben selber, kann Leben von sich aus entstehen? Nein, ah, sie sind diejenigen, die Leben entstehen. Aber sind wir dann in einer anderen Dimension? Also haben die dann gesagt, wir machen jetzt den Urknall und gucken zu? Das weiß ich nicht. Oder sind wir nur auf anderen Planeten ganz weit weg? Dimension, genau bei Dimension hört man ein bisschen auf. Alles klar. Davor weiß ich alles, aber Dimension, da habe ich noch nicht ganz durchdrungen. Okay, das heißt, es ist immer ein Kreislauf, auch unsere Zivilisation wird irgendwann an einem Punkt sein, wo sie sagen, lass uns mal rausfinden. Oder eine Simulation, gibt es ja auch die Theorie, eine Simulation machen oder halt, wir werfen einen Urknall irgendwo rein und schauen, was passiert. Ich glaube, es wird so sein, wir versuchen zu gucken, wie entsteht da nicht Leben, werden so ein Mini-Universum bauen, merken aber, ah, okay, da entsteht kein Leben von alleine, wir sind der Schlüssel quasi. Und dann eine Bakterie wird so reinfallen gelassen in diese Petrischale, dann entsteht da Leben und dadurch checken wir als Zivilisation, ah, wir, das Leben, was wir sind, kommt auch von oben, weißt du?
Auf uns wurde auch mal irgendwann so ein Partikel gefallen lassen. Aber würden wir da nicht versuchen, irgendwie mit der höheren Ebene Kontakt aufzunehmen? Ja, ja, klar. Weil wenn wir gecheckt haben, Moment mal, wir schaffen die nächste untere Stufe, also wurden wir auch geschaffen, dann können wir sagen, was ist denn das Ergebnis des Experiments? Nee, das ist so ein Daumen nach oben. Warum müssen wir noch Kontakt aufnehmen? Wir wissen ja dann auch alles. Naja, weil wenn wir das Experiment ja selber machen, hat die Ebene über uns ja schon die Ergebnisse des Experiments. Ja, dann hauen wir so einen Daumen hoch. Ja, aber wir wollen ja wissen, habt ihr auch Angels? Ja. Also es sind, ja, wirklich? Ja. Moment mal, wir haben exakt dieselbe Musik gemacht, die ihr auch hattet. Ja. Also das ist alles sozusagen schon
im Menschen angelegt. Und ihr habt auch
Wetten, dass und Verstehen Sie Spaß
und Batman, all das
habt ihr auch, oder wie?
Ja, okay.
Ist auch sehr anstrengend zu sprechen für die,
weil die so riesige,
die sind so groß. Lautsprecher. Ach so, die sind viel grösser als wir.
Ja, natürlich. Weil die müssen dann ganz leise sprechen, oder was? Warum ist das so anstrengend? Weil die so riesige, die sind so groß. Lautspreche. Ach so, die sind viel grösser als wir. Ja, natürlich. Weil die müssen dann ganz leise sprechen oder was. Warum ist das so anstrengend? Weil die so riesige Organe haben. Ach, verstehe. Aha. Okay. Gut. Okay. Ja, kann sein. Absolut. Kann sein. Und Nordkorea ist unser kleines Projekt dann auch, oder wie so ein Nebenprojekt. Nordkorea ist jetzt gerade so ein bisschen die Vorstufe davon. Nordkorea ist gerade so die Vorstufe von wir entwickeln, leben und gucken. Weil das so ein eingezäuntes Bereich ist und leider hat es zu viel Einfluss, also negativen Einfluss hat man in der Doku auch gesehen. Also ich frage, ob die Angels irgendwann komponieren, ob die irgendwann sagen, ohne es je gehört zu haben. Aber die kennen es ja schon. Meinst du? Nicht alle jetzt.
Stell dir mal vor, du hast noch nie Angels gehört, komponierst das, denkst dir, Alter, ich bin der beste Komponist der Welt und stellt sich raus, hat schon jemand komponiert. Aber du hast es selbstständig komponiert. Komponiert, dass du immer komponiert sagst, ist geschrieben. Ja, natürlich. Angels schreibt man eine Symphonie komponiert. Ach Gott, jetzt kommt wieder Föhrtor, Stefan. Einmal auf den Wagner-Festspielen irgendwie in die Bohle gefallen und jetzt denkt er, jetzt ist der große Künstler. Also das ist ja wirklich lächerlich. Ich bin als Kind auf dem grünen Hügel in die Bohle von den blauen Mädels gefallen. Ja. Die uns übrigens geschrieben haben und gesagt, wir saufen nicht nur. Irgendeine von den blauen Mädels hat uns geschrieben und meinte, hey, Entschuldigung, könnt ihr uns bitte nicht so darstellen, dass wir nur saufen. Damit die blauen Mädels nicht gecancelt werden. Blaue Mädels ist so eine Art Eingreiftruppe bei den Bayreuther Festspielen, die eingreifen, falls jemand nicht leidenschaftlich genug Wagner mag, dann greifen die ein. Ja, ich finde da die Nachricht nicht mehr. Ich trinke aber auch Bode. Aber ich glaube, die machen einen richtig guten Job. Die machen einen super Job. Das haben wir nie bestritten. Aber ganz ehrlich, liebe blaue Mädels, ich glaube nicht, dass eure Chefs und Chefinnen diesen Podcast hören. Ja, kann sein. Kommt von eurem grossen grünen Hügel runter. Und hört nicht auf das, was die roten Mädels sagen, okay? Die lügen und das wissen alle. Die lügen und betrügen. Okay, lasst euch von denen nicht verunsichern. Apropos verunsichern, ich war auf einer Hochzeit die letzten Tage und Wochen. Nein! Ich bin großer Fan von Zeremonien, von Ritualen, liebe ich. Finde ich großartig, Bärligungen, auch was für dich. Super, finde ich super. Gibt es ja immer weniger, Einfluss der Kirche sinkt. Bärligungen gibt es immer weniger? Hochzeiten. Rituale und Ritualeriten und Zeremonien im Allgemeinen. Und auch bei Hochzeiten machen ja viele nicht mehr den christlichen Kram. Ja, kleines Beispiel, meine Cousine hat irgendwann beschlossen, ich gehe nicht mehr zur Kirche, mit in die Kirche Weihnachten. Weil sie dann gemerkt hat, das ist alles nichts für die Religion. Und da habe ich sie so gut mal zur Seite genommen und gesagt, das ist auch alles nichts für mich. Aber wie geil sind denn diese Rituale? Ja. Du willst doch sehen, wie die das Krippenspiel aufhören mit ihren merkwürdigen Geschichten und offensichtlich Feedback in den Mikrofonen und so. Und überhaupt, wie kommt denn ein Mikrofon in die Kirche? Kaufen die das bei Thomann.de? Klinge das umsonst? Legt das jemand da in diesen Klingelbeutel rein, wenn du bei Thomann arbeitest? Wo wird das geliefert? Ja. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, okay, ich komme mit. Du bist der moderne Missionar. Da er einfach sagt, ja, okay, gut, dann schaue ich es mir an. Aber das finde ich geil, aber es war eine nicht religiöse, nicht christliche Zeremonie, sondern irgendein... Standesamtlich. Nee, nee, nee, es war schon die Trauung, die Feier. Aber irgendein Dude hatte die Aufgabe... Wait, wait, wait, wait. Trauung, also in der Kirche? Nein, keine Kirche. Es war halt einfach eine Traufeier. Eine Trauerfeier. Und das heißt, irgendjemand hatte die Aufgabe, denkt ihr mal eine Trauungszeremonie aus, vergiss mal die letzten dreitausend Jahre christliche Ritus, sondern überleg dir das mal selber. So, und jetzt braucht man diese Menschen, die man in Kasten sperrt, in so einen in Watte gehüllten Kasten, die man großzieht, weißt du, die halt nicht primed sind mit so dreitausend lame, lame Geschichte. Ja, so mit Schleier und Ring und so, Nee, denk dir das selber aus. Er hat gesagt, lass uns Reis werfen. Nein! Lass uns so ein kleines Mädchen so blättern. Nein, das bringt da nichts. Mir tatsächlich mal, es ist ja ein Riesenproblem, es gibt ja verschiedene Hobbys und angenommen, dein Hobby sind, ich denke mir, Zeremonien und Rituale aus. Wenig Anungsmöglichkeiten. Es gibt wenige Slots. Event-Management sagt man auch, glaube ich, mittlerweile dazu. Zeremonienmeister. Ja, Zeremonienmeister, glaube ich, gibt es schon noch. Wenn du sagst, halt, nee, aber nicht ausführen. Ich will nicht der Zeremonienmeister sein, ich will der Zeremoniendesigner sein. Ich will der sein, der sich überlegt, erst gehen die die Treppe runter, dann stehen links und rechts die Leute. Dann sind dann wieder rauf. Ja, rauf. Dann geht erst die Braut runter, der guckt nach oben, der Bräutigam wirft Reis und die Braut versucht, es aufzufangen im Mund. Dann ruft der Pfarrer laut als Angels! Ein Song, I sit and wait! Und dann bricht aber ganz schnell einer ab, dann kommt der Hubschrauber mit einer langen Strickleiter direkt runter, die Braut greift die Strickleiter, wird hochgehoben von dem Hubschrauber, der Hubschrauber kreist um die Gemeinde herum, wie an einem Kettenkarussell. Und dabei spielt Wagners Wackyrenritt dabei. Und dann ergibt ihr auch die Schleppe von Brautkleid total Sinn, weil das sieht halt mega cool aus, wenn die an dem Hubschrauber herumgewedelt wird. Und sie hat ja davor Reis gegessen, von daher ist es sicher. Und dann kommt es wieder runter. Milchreis. So jemand, das auszudenken, weil tatsächlich bei mir kam mal ein guter Freund aus der Uni-Zeit zu mir und meinte, du pass auf, falls du mal heiratest, ich hätte eine Phönix-Zeremonie, die ich dir anbieten könnte zur Trauungsfeier,
Traufeier.
Traufe.
Falls du dich traust,
wenn du einmal in die Traufe gehst,
von der Wiege in die Traufe,
von W nach T,
dann würde ich bei T
auf dich warten,
mit meiner Födelin Phoenix.
Und ich dachte mir, wow,
ich hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nie mit einer Frau gesprochen, aber ich dachte mir, das wäre es wert, nur um diese Föhnik-Zeremonie. Aber so ungefragt einfach, um Braut und Bräutigam so eine Riesenschlange zu legen. So wie man das kennt, wenn du jetzt so eine Schlange mal, das kennt man ja bei so, keine Ahnung, so Urlaubsfoto sieht man, dass manchmal wieder so eine Schlangeange um dich herumgelegt wird. Und ha, guck mal, ich habe... Was? Ja, doch. Eine lebende Schlange. Ja, das kennt man doch schon mal so. Wie man mit dem Bali auf dem Markt oder so kriegt man dann bei Juckung Klaas auch ständig. Aber wenn dann so eine große Schlange, so eine Anaconda um die Beide gelegt, so nach dem Motto... Wie gehört? Nee, gibt es ja auch nicht, macht ja niemand. Aber so bei einem Bräutigam oder Braut, finde ich, so eine grosse Schlange rumzulegen, weil nach dem Motto dass sie beide zerquetscht werden sozusagen ja, im schlimmsten Fall, ja, aber dann sterben sie beide sie wären bereit, gemeinsam zerquetscht zu werden bis dass die Anaconda euch scheidet bis dass die Anaconda euch zerquetscht in guten wie in zerquetschenden Anaconda-Zeiten sollt ihr zueinander stehen Genau. Deswegen stehe ich für ein Problem, ob ich wirklich dann sage, ich will die Phoenix-Zeremonie. Einmal Phoenix-Zeremonie bitte. Wir brauchen neue Zeremonien. Aber kann der nicht generell einfach anbieten, Zeremonien, wie so eine Speisekarte, wo halt da verschiedene Zeremonien, die Phoenix-Zeremonie, die bunte Sause, das Emoji-Emoji-Kon. Die Emoji-Kon, ja genau. Und dann einfach zu sagen, neue Rituale, neue Zeremonien mit, jeder muss eine Rede halten. Ja, aber grob das Ziel immer, am Ende finden zwei Menschen in einer Art Traufe zueinander. Ja, oder man macht halt eine Zeremonie,
die überhaupt gar keinen Sinn hat,
also wo nichts sich erreicht,
niemand wird beerdigt, sondern man
kommt, es werden Rollen definiert,
der hat jede verschiedene
Aufgaben, der eine muss eine Rede halten,
die andere wirft. Jede Feier, du beschreibst gerade
jede Feier, jeder hat grob irgendein
Ziel, nichts ist ersichtlich. Jeder macht sein eigenes Ding, aber dass du einfach sagst, heute machen wir das Magnesium-Fest und jeder weiss, ah okay, ja gut, Fest ist auch schon zu zelebratorisch, einfach nur die Magnesium-Zeremonie, die Quecksilber-Zeremonie, einmal im Jahr trifft man sich, wirft Dinge in die Luft, misst gegenseitig Fieber bei anderen Leuten und
eine Motocross-Session ist auch
dabei. Ja, einer muss ja quasi der
erste Mensch gewesen sein, der so einen Baum,
so eine Tanne ins Wohnzimmer
gestellt hat und große
Kugeln drangehangen
hat. Wer war der Erste, der das gemacht hat?
Von daher finde ich es ja gar nicht so schlecht, mal wieder
neu zu denken.
Was gibt es denn, was ist das neueste Fest? Die kommen ja alle so kirchlichen Ursprung, Ostern vielleicht mit Ostereiern und so. Ja, halt so Tag der Deutschen Einheit oder halt so politische Ereignisse oder 9-11 oder irgendwie so was. Auch hier, Tag der Deutschen Einheit, finde ich Anaconda nicht das Schlechteste. Lass mich mal ausreden. Ne, lass mich alle mal ausreden. Nein, hey, nein, nein. Niemand unterbricht dich, Stefan. Niemand unterbricht dich.
Weil Anaconda wäre jetzt nicht so schlecht, um auch so Einigkeit zu zeigen.
Aber warum denn Einigkeit bei einer Anaconda?
Menschen werden zusammengewickelt mit einer Anaconda.
Ja, aber das weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe jetzt schon 90 Anacondas zu Hause.
Okay.
Wie lang sind die?
Jeweils 15 Meter.
15 Meter! Wie viele Menschen kann man damit gleichzeitig zerdrücken? Zehn. Okay. Gut, also haben wir hundertfünfzig Leute. Pi mal Radius Quadrat war das doch, ne? Pi Quadrat mal Radius. Weiss die Anaconda das? Kann man die Anaconda das fragen? Wie viele können sie so gleichzeitig zerdrücken? Anaconda ist sehr tollpatschig. Anaconda. Weißt du, was mich wundert, wenn ich eine Schlange sehe und mich jemand fragen würde, und ich hätte noch nie, ich käme aus dieser Petrischale raus, auf Urlaub, und dann zeigt mir jemand eine Schlange und sagt mir, fragt mich, was meinst du, wie bewegt die sich? Was ist das? Ja, erst mal, was ist das? Zweitens würde man mir fragen, was meinst du, wie bewegt die sich fort, wenn ich nicht wüsste, wie eine Schlange sich fortbewegt und man mir die zeigen würde. Ich würde sagen, die rollt seitlich. Die rollt seitlich. Mir gefällt, du denkst, wie eine so eine AI. Die rollt durch die Gegend, weil die ist rund. Die sieht aus, das ist das Tier, das am nächsten an einem Rad dran ist. Warum rollt die sich nicht seitlich? Nee, ich würde nicht denken, dass sie seitlich rollt. Ich erkläre auch warum. Weil sie hinten schmaler wird, würde ich eher denken, wenn sie rellt, weil die ist so eishörnchenförmig, streng genommen, also leicht vereinfacht, weil die hinten schmaler wird, bis sie sich irgendwann in Luft auflöst. Weißt du, die wird nach vorne hin dicker. Die hört nie auf, die wird immer kleiner. Irgendwann ist sie auf Molekular- und Atomebene. Deswegen niemals hinter Schlangen her schlurfen. Man kann da drauf treten. Die sind noch zehn Meter länger. Ich springe immer drüber. Ihr seht das noch nicht, weil die so dünn werden. Ja, das ist schon klug. Aber deswegen würde ich eher, wenn ich die wüsste, dass die sich fortbewegen, würde ich eher denken, die rollt immer im Kreis. Ach so, verstehe, aber der Kreis ist vergleichsweise gross. Also deshalb haben wir einen Radius von 15 Kilometern. Rollt die so rum? Rollt die rum. Aber die würde nie an sich so ... Das ist halt das Revier, das ist das Revier von der Schlange, wo du es schon direkt eingebaut hast. Deswegen haben grössere Schlangen auch grössere Reviere, weil die grösseren Radius haben, wenn die rollen.
Und raupen so, hold my hold my
cocon.
Rollen sich noch anders.
Die machen weder die Schlange noch den
Roller, die machen ja den
den
den Raubler.
Ganz merkwürdig.
Robben. Die robben sich nach vorn, streng genommen. Im Grunde Robben, die mehr als Robben es tun, das stimmt schon, ja, Robben, ja, das stimmt, das stimmt schon, ja, eigentlich ein merkwürdiges Wort. Robben haben fucking Wert bekommen, Jesus, what the fuck, ja, schon, eigenes Wort, das man nicht mal für sie verwendet, man würde nicht sagen Robben, Robben, man würde sagen Robben, Schwimmen, Robben, Kriechen, Kriechen, ja. Wie war denn dann jetzt diese Zeremonie? Toll, schön, schöne Zeremonie, toll. Ich bin ja ein emotionaler Typ und ich warte aber eigentlich bei... Bei dir liefen die Tränen runter, bei dir kuderten die Tränen. Ja, doch, das kann man schon sagen, auch natürlich auch ein bisschen wegen Heuschnupfen, aber ansonsten ganz, ganz tolle Sachen. Richtig. Robten deine Wange. Robten Gensüden, den ganzen Anzug herunter. Und auch da, wie der Anzug nie benutzt, merke ich, oh fuck, ich habe Motten anscheinend. Ich bin auch Teil der Motten Gang. Ja, sag ich ja. Fucking zerfressener Anzug, merkst du dann an der Hochzeit, dass du überall Löcher hast. Und also ich mag ja Hochzeiten einfach, weil die clever designt sind, dramaturgisch. Weil wer auch immer die Hochzeit designt hat, hat diesen Moment eingebaut. Dieses, wenn jemand gegen die Eheschliessung ist, möger jetzt sprechen oder für immer schweigen. Und das ist der coolste Moment, weil der wurde doch nur gebaut für Hollywood-Filme. Als Kind dachte ich immer, der darf dann wirklich nichts mehr sagen oder für immer schweigen. Der darf nicht mehr reden. Und dann ist auch Leute, die was dagegen haben, sind sehr leicht zu identifizieren auf der Aftershow. Deswegen hast du danach immer alle Leute angesprochen. Und dann, aber Moment mal, du hast was gegen die Hochzeit, raus mit dir. Und das finde ich immer der coolste Moment und ich glaube, jeder
Anwesende wünscht sich, dass da was
passiert. Kleiner Spoiler, bei der
Zeremonie wurde das ausgelassen. Was ich
eine Frechheit finde, weil ich hatte
am Handy noch den alten
Schulschwarm, der irgendwie
sagen will, ich konnte nicht kommen, leider,
aber ich bin per Skype
zugeschaltet und
ich wollte sagen, du, ich hab dich immer geliebt, ich bin gegen diese Ehe. Hört ihr mich? Könnt ihr mich hören? Ja, alle hören dich. Ja, wir hören dich. Wir hören dich. Ach okay, gut. Soll ich es nochmal sagen? Jetzt haben es die Airports verbunden. Nein, sorry, sorry. Was ist denn das WLAN-Passwort hier? Entschuldigung. Also ganz in der Gemeinde hat gefehlt, was ich eine Frechheit finde. Auch Scherze können gemacht werden. Ja, klar. Scherze können gemacht werden. Und ich glaube, jeder Anwesende wünscht sich, dass jemand aufsteht und sagt, die sind eigentlich Geschwister. Ich habe doch mal den Familienstammbaum rausgekramt aus dem Familienarchiv. Und die sind miteinander verwandt, die dürfen nicht heiraten. Aber auch dieses, ich mag auch diesen fiesen Blick der beiden ins Publikum. Ja. Diesen kurze Moment, wo wer von euch wächst, dann hat was zu sagen. Was soll denn da auch passieren? Also ja, vor allem warum für immer schweigen? Es kann sich ja auch ergeben, dass die Hochzeit für beide nicht so gut ist. Na ja, ich glaube, wo so Hochzeiten entwickelt wurden, da war das schon wichtig, dass diese Hochzeit dann auch nicht mehr angezweifelt wird, weil es geht ja eigentlich darum, um die Kinder, wer der Vater ist. Weil du musst ja die Thronfolge bestimmen und du weißt ja bei Kindern nicht, wer der Vater ist, deswegen musst du sagen, wenn die verheiratet sind, dann ist gesetzlich der Ehemann der Vater. Völlig egal, ob es der biologische ist, kann man im Mittelalter nicht ausfinden. Das heißt, du kannst dann nicht mehr sagen, Moment, ich zweifle die Ehe an, weil damit würdest du die Thronfolge anzweifeln.
Deswegen müssen die denen die Chance
geben, wenn ihr da was dagegen habt,
dann sagt es jetzt oder nie wieder.
Weil wir können nicht sagen, wenn
der König... So, den setzt sich bitte einfach.
Deswegen haben wir es eigentlich übersprungen.
Genau, aber deswegen meine ich, falls jemand was
dagegen hat... Bitte fahren Sie fort. Nein, fahren Sie nicht
fort, weil ich habe jetzt nichts dagegen, aber ich habe was
dagegen, dass der Part ausgelassen wurde, weil wenn irgendwann... du kannst nicht den Rest deines Lebens sich damit rumschlagen. Quentin, bitte, lass mich nicht bereuen, dich eingeladen zu haben. Und warum hast du überall Löcher? Woher soll ich denn wissen, dass ich Motten habe? Ich gucke mir die noch nicht an. Danke.
Kommt nicht mehr. Jetzt nicht.
Kommt nicht mehr.
Der Skype-Klingelton kommt nicht mehr?
Frage. Kam der, als man jemanden angerufen hat oder als man angerufen wurde?
Antwort. Ich höre ihn noch, wenn ich selbst anrufe.
Meine Antwort. Ich habe ihn nicht gehört, als ich jemanden angerufen habe. als ich angerufen wurde, kann ich nicht sagen, weil ich nicht angerufen wurde. Antwort auf die Frage, die wir letzte Woche gestellt haben. Letzte Woche ging es ums Thema Kopf ab, Arm ab, Bein ab, die grosse Amputationsshow mit Stefan Tietze und Florian Tietze. Wir haben uns gefragt, wir haben alle im Erste-Hilfe-Kurs gelernt, falls der Kopf ab ist, schön einpacken in Eiswasser. Nicht in Eis, nicht in Wasser, in Eiswasser. Plastiktüte in der Weile. Gleiche Mengen Wasser und Eis? Genau. Ja, aber muss man die, ja, das weiß ich nicht genau. So, und wir haben uns gefragt, klappt das denn wirklich, wenn jemand den Arm verliert und man packt den dann in Plastik, in Eis ein und fährt dann ins Krankenhaus, bringt das wirklich was? Und stellt sich raus, uns hat niemand geschrieben, bei dem das erfolgreich passiert ist. Eine Hörerin hat uns geschrieben, die hat gesagt, sie hat mal irgendwo am Fließband gearbeitet und hat Finger verloren, also so halbe Finger verloren, nicht spezifiziert an welchem Fließband, an der Kettensägenproduktion, wo laufende Kettensägen an ihr vorbeihuschen den ganzen Tag. Und die hat gesagt, sie hat alles richtig gemacht, sie hat einen Kollegen gebeten, ihre Finger in Plastiktüten einzuwickeln, die wiederum in Plastiktüten zusammen mit Eiswasser zu tun, sind sie ins Krankenhaus gefahren und da wurde ihr gesagt, können wir nicht annähen.
Ganz kurz, aber sie klingt wie die abgeklärteste Person der Welt. Ja, absolut. Entschuldigung, können Sie mir
kurz helfen? Sorry, ganz kurz, ich bin
in Pause leider, ich bin in Mittagspause,
weiß ich. Nee, ganz kurz, nur weil
Sorry, ich bin gerade auf dem Weg. Alles klar,
freie Kollegen von Ihnen, danke schön. Alles klar, gut.
Sie klingt wie die abgeklärteste Person, geht es
am anderen und sagt dann, Entschuldigung, können wir kurz diese Finger,
die habe ich gerade verloren. Ja. Auf dem Fließband da hinten, A19. Du hast deine fucking Finger verloren! Ja, bleiben Sie ganz ruhig, alle vier. Okay, okay, fuck, fuck, fuck, ich rufe an, ich rufe an, fuck, wen rufe ich an, welche Finger? Nee, zunächst einmal, fuck, fuck, alles gut, alles gut, alles gut, fuck, Herr Franzen, einfach Plastiktüten besorgen. Okay, welche, wie groß? Wie, wie groß? Kleine,. Okay, alles klar. Ist auch ganz normal, dass man sich an diesem Punkt erst mal ein bisschen aufbaut. Da atmen wir normal durch. Und dann finde ich es total mega toll von Ihnen. Aber nur wenn es nicht zu viel Arbeit macht. Wasser und Eis. Eis, wo soll ich jetzt Eis herbekommen? Ich habe kein Eis einfach so rumliegen. Dann machen wir kaltes Wasser, ist gar kein Problem. Kriegen wir bestimmt hin. Vielleicht Erbsen, wir haben gehalte Erbsen, wir haben gefrorene Erbsen. Alles klar, nehmen wir gefrorene Erbsen. Okay. Wieso haben wir hier gefrorene Erbsen, aber kein Eis? Na gut. Sie klingt, als hätte sie jetzt alles im Griff. Ja, sie war super abgeklärt, aber dann auch, stelle ich mir vor, wenn du im Krankenhaus ankommst und es heißt, wir können die nicht annähen, würde ich sagen, wir können die nicht fucking annähen. Ich habe alles genau so gemacht, wie ich es machen sollte. Also das ist wirklich unfair, dann zu sagen, die könnt ihr nicht annehmen. Aber sie hat geschrieben, je kleiner das Körperteil ist, das abgesämmelt ist. Lass mich raten, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es, wie du nachwächst. Nein. Nein, nein, nein. Desto unwahrschein... Mach A, B, oder C.
Okay. A, je kleiner das Körperteil, desto wahrscheinlicher, dass es wieder angenäht werden kann. B, je kleiner das Körperteil, desto unwahrscheinlicher ist es, dass es angenäht werden kann. Oder, je kleiner das Körperteil, desto riskanter ist die Operation. A, B oder C? Ich sag, A, je kleiner das Körperteil, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass es wieder angenäht werden kann. Möchten Sie es einloggen? Ich nehme die offensichtlich falsche, weil den 30-30-30-Joker. Ich nehme den 30-30-30-30. Sie haben sich für eins entschieden? Mhm. Und diese Antwort? Ist falsch! Nein! Nein, jetzt muss ich Ihnen Geld geben. Je kleiner das Körperteilt, desto unwahrscheinlicher ist es, dass es wieder angelehrt werden kann, weil dann die Nervenbahnen irgendwie nicht mehr stabil genug sind oder was auch immer, keine Ahnung. So, beziehungsweise, ich glaube, was Sie genau, nee, nee, nee, das stimmt schon. Ja, ja, ja, ich habe die Frage nicht gemacht, aber gut, ich versuche es. Das stimmt schon. Es heißt, desto höher die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das wieder abgestossen wird, das Körperteil. Annähen kann man ja alles immer irgendwo, das ist ja kein Problem. Die Frage ist nur, wird es dann vom Körper angenommen oder sagt der Körper, Aret, weg damit, das ist eine Weintraube, eine Rosine, die gehört nicht zu mir als Körper, weg damit. Husten, auslösen, in drei, zwei, eins. Aber wenn ich jetzt so einen grossen Arm, so einen richtig schönen grossen Arm rechts, wenn ich jetzt einen grossen Arm von dem anderen drangenäht bekäme, nochmal, neun Arm. Jetzt sind wir wohl ganz anders, jetzt sind wir in Frankenstein-Territorium. Stringgenommen waren wir auch gerade so in Frankenstein-Territorium. Aber wenn du von einem anderen, das weiß ich nicht, das sind wahrscheinlich wieder ganz... Das ist doch die Aussage, die sie tätigt. Nein, sie war Annika tätig. Wenn du dein eigenes Körperteil verlierst, willst du lieber ein grosses Teil verlieren, wenn es darum geht, ob die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch sein soll, dass es vom Körper wieder angenommen wird. Weil dann kann man da mit ganz langen Nerven dann irgendwie da noch rum... Was weiß ich denn? Wahrscheinlich hat der Arzt es auch nur gesagt, ich glaube ja eh, dass es alles Bullshit ist mit dem Eis. Und dass die Ärzte und die Erste-Hilfe-Stationen das nur erzählen, damit die Leute nicht keine Panik haben, sondern zumindest die Hoffnung haben, dass noch irgendwas passiert mit ihren Körperteilen. Weil sonst geht es denen wahrscheinlich noch schlechter. Wen kann man denn mal anrufen mit dem Scheiß-Eis-Problem? Wir rufen nächste Woche mal jemanden an mit dem Eis-Problem. Sollen wir mal einen Krankenwagen anrufen? Nee, das jetzt nicht. Aber so, also wir warten, wir geben euch da draußen noch eine Woche, dass die Ärzte... Okay, Ultimatum. Ja, dass die Ärzte mal hervorkommen, lassen Sie mich durch, ich bin arztmässig, um uns zu erklären, stimmt das, stimmt das nicht. Wir lassen euch halt durch. Wie viel Eis, wie viel Wasser. Ja, und stimmt es oder ist es Bullshit? Und wenn bis nächste Woche keine Antwort kommt, dann lassen wir die Sache platzen. Okay? Dann machen wir hier einen Riesen... Dann könnt ihr sehen, wo ihr bleibt mit abgetrennten Gliedmassen. Dann machen wir eine Riesennummer, weil dann sagen wir nicht beim ersten Hilfekurs, wer was gegen diese Inhalte hat, der möchte jetzt was sagen oder für immer schweigen, sagen die... Ich stehe jetzt auf und ich calle Bullshit auf die Eistüte. Wie viel Zeit gibst du der Ehe? Ich finde ja ohnehin, dass dieses Wissen, dass jede zweite Ehe geschieden wird oder so heutzutage, mehr in die Ehezeremonie einfließen sollte. Und das meine ich gar nicht zynisch, sondern weil so viel Druck auf das Brautpaar
ausgeübt wird. Eben nicht mehr.
Nee, doch eben schon noch. Ich finde gerade nicht mehr.
Heute ist der schönste Tag eures Lebens, ihr seid
für immer zusammen. Ich hätte gerne in der Rede
gesagt sowas wie, hey Leute, wenn es nicht klappt,
auch okay, sucht euch
jemand anderen, ciao.
So dass man einfach sagt, ja schön,
wenn es klappt, aber...
Zehn Minuten Rede, oder ist das deine ganze Rede? Das ist alles. Okay. Hast du eine Rede gehalten? Ich habe eine Rede gehalten. Nein. Kleine Rede, aber natürlich auch immer schön aus dem Jackett vier Diner-Vier-Zettel rausnehmen. Aus dem löchrigen Jackett. Aus dem löchrigen Jackett, aus dem Mottenloch, vier Diner-Vier-Seiten rausholen und erst mal zerreissen. Ja, die Blätter zerreissen. There ain't no rules, motherfucker. Und dann sagen, und dann schön die Konfetti. Aber der Kumpel auch direkt so. Dann schön die Konfetti direkt dem Blumenmädchen ins Gesicht werfen und dann sagen, pass auf. Mic drop. Erst mal Mic drop, mit dem Mic drop erst mal anfangen. Das Mikrofon noch weglegen, finde ich gut. Wenn sie zu den Leuten kommen, erstmal ins Publikum gehen. Und so ganz nach hinten gehen, damit alle sich so umdrehen müssen. Das ist ja, glaube ich, eh, weil das ist ja schon gewollt, oder? Dass das Brautpaar von hinten kommt und alle schön den Storch machen müssen, um nach hinten zu gucken. Und der Traumarsch, Entschuldigung, Hochzeitsmarsch von Richard Wagner.
Aber halt mit Reggae-Komponente.
Also anscheinend gab es auf dem Keyboard so einen Reggae-Beat.
So ein Bossa- und finde ich schon gut. Und ja, ich habe eine kleine Rede gehalten und habe gesagt, hey Leute, cool, dass ihr da seid, aber pass auf. Und dann jetzt, ach fuck, alles, jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz die Zettel, und dann alle Zettel kurz. Genau, jetzt habe ich mir Blackout. Oh, scheiße, das ist mir noch nie passiert. Kann ich kurz noch mal die, können Sie mir kurz die Zettel noch mal geben? Ja, hier, können Sie mir kurz, was steht hier? Für immer, nee, das ist, nee, das ist glaube ich falsch, das ist, naja, das ist ganz anders. Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung. Sorry, sorry, tut mir richtig leid. Okay, Freestyle. Wie lange war deine Rede? 34 Minuten. Wie lange war deine Rede? Wirklich? Nur ganz kurz. Jeder konnte einfach nur so einen Gruss sagen und da habe ich auch gesagt, Leute, was geht, ich kenne euch nicht so gut. Warst du dieser Künstlerfreund, den man gerne einlädt, in der lockersten Rede, spießigste Rede? Alles Künstler, alle coole Typen, alle coole Einstecktücher und ich war von Motten zerfressen. Aber war cool. Und wie gesagt, ich bin großer Fan von Zeremonien, ich mag das, dann weiss man, was passiert auf so einer Hochzeit, das ist nicht so, wenn du auf eine Party gehst, wo immer dann so, was mache ich nach zehn Minuten? Ich habe mich jetzt schon vor jedem erfolgreich versteckt. Ich bin schön Mambo No. 5 ausgewichen auf dem Dancefloor. Und wie geht es jetzt weiter? Wie sieht mein restlicher Abend aus? Bei Hochzeiten, weißt du was? Bei mir musst du auch eine Rede halten. Bei dir? Ja. Kleine Rede. Oh nee, jetzt habe ich jetzt schon Druck. Aber bei dir mache ich mir keine Sorgen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, diese ganze Feier wird ein Riesendesaster. Nee, ich will bei dir der Zeremonienmeister sein. Ich will bei dir einfach in so einer ... DJ heißt das doch, MC. Master of Ceremony. Du willst MC bei mir sein. Ich will MC, aber ich will nicht DJ sein. Ich will nur MC sein. Und ich will da kommen in so einer riesigen roten Robe, mit so grossen pechschwarzen Flügeln auf dem Rücken. Das ist geil, wenn du um meine Braut zu ärgern, auch in dem gleichen Brautkleid rankommst. Aber es ist halt nicht sie ist halt nicht sauer, sondern es ist irgendwie auch lustig, dass du das gleiche, aber das gleiche Brautkleid. Und ich würde vor allem sagen, und hier kommen die Bräute und dann kommt so Breakdance-Musik und dann kommen so 20 Tänzerinnen, die alle das exakt gleiche Brautkleid tragen wie die Braut und die Breakdancen rum und dann vermischen die sich auch in der Party Crowd. Und niemand weiss mehr genau, wer die moderne Hochzeitspiele mit so Doppelgängern, also Doppelgängerinnen, angenommen, du bist der Kumpel von ihm und kennst sie nicht. Und er sagt, du kannst mir ein Spiel vorbereiten und so, ja klar. Und dann sagst du, okay, wir casten 20 Doppelgängerinnen, alle sehen gleich aus, du stehst immer mindestens 50 Meter weiter weg und musst durch geschicktes Nachfragen herausfinden, wer die eine ist. Oh ja, fisch gut. Oder am Tanzstil. Da müssen sie alle tanzen und er muss sagen, er muss erst mal zehn Leute rausrulen. Und wenn er ... Die haben alle so eine Guy-Fawkes-Maske auf. Ja, genau. Oder diesen Schleier gibt es ja auch teilweise bei Hochzeiten. Oh ja! Vielleicht ist das die ursprüngliche Idee von einem Schleier, dass man nicht ... Und dann sagst du so, okay, erste Runde tanzen, am Tanzstil erkennen. Und dann müssen wir alle tanzen und er muss zehn Frauen rauswählen, die es nicht sind. Die tragen die Nummern oder wie läuft das? Genau, da hat er 22 raus, 49 raus, warum gibt es so viele? Die gehen ans Buffet. Nummer drei raus, alle weg. Ja. So und wenn er auf dem Wege bis zur letzten Runde, es gibt fünf Runden, seine Frau rausgewählt hat, dann wird die Hochzeit
annulliert. Und das geht von vorne los.
Und nächste Runde
mit, man darf jeder
Frau eine Frage stellen. Genau.
Ja, ist das moderne Hochzeit?
Ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber es ist eh demütigend.
Ist eh demütigend.
Diese Brautspiele so, dass es
gab, sie nicht heiraten. Wollen wir nicht heiraten. Aus steuerlichen Gründen einfach. Uns gegenseitig? Ja. Oder wir beide jemand Dritten. Mir macht das nicht Sinn, dass wir beide heiraten aus steuerlichen Gründen. Ich glaube, ich kann nur aus Liebe heiraten, Stefan, tut mir leid. Ehrlich jetzt? Und ich mag dich gern als Podcast-Co-Moderator. Sehr sachlich formuliert jetzt, aber ... Und ich finde, du machst einen guten Job. Ja, okay. Das ist schon gar nicht so Debatte. Das habe ich dich gar nicht gefragt. Darüber hinaus möchte ich es dabei belassen. Nee, ist ja okay. Ich habe nur gefragt, ob wir aus steuerlichen Gründen heiraten. Wie gesagt. Kann ich wieder aufstehen, oder muss ich hier knien bleiben? Braucht es mehr als das. Ich glaube nur, dass du andere geheiratet hättest. Liegt es an mir? Ich könnte es gerne auch mal pünktlicher zur Aufnahme kommen. Und dann heiratest du mich. Vielleicht? Die wirsteste Rom-Com aller Zeiten. Eigentlich auch nicht schlecht, so eine Rom-Com, die sich so komplett, so eine antiromantische Rom-Com. Man ist auf der Suche nach jemandem, der einen steuerlich heiratet. Und es ist halt so, es gibt keine Cute-Meets, sondern es ist einfach nur so, hey, ich habe finanzielle Schwierigkeiten. Es gibt nur pragmatische Müsse. Nur super pragmatisch und es gibt auch die Szene am Anfang, wo er so durch die Haare kringelt und dann irgendwie so das Gesetzbuch liest und sich dann so auf ganz süssem pinken Papier die Paragraphen rausschreibt und dann so einfaltet und so Kolleginnen gibt, so süße Herzblättchen, wo diese Paragraphen draufstehen. Ja, und dieses Süße, bei Instagram gucken nochmal und Bilder von dir finden und verliebt gucken, ist auch so ein reines, einfach nur Einkommen vergleichen, so Steuerbescheinigungen, so Gästerbescheinigungen nebeneinander halten und dann so einkringeln mit so einem Herz, dann die Summen, die man besparen würde an Steuern und so. Ja, oder auf Tinder, könntest du mir nochmal deine Einkommenserklärung schicken, drei Herzchen? Habe ich doch schon. Und dann in der Schlussszene steht er dann so im Regen mit so grossen Pappplatten im Garten, wo dann so aufgerechnet ist, wie viel man steuerlich sparen könnte jedes Jahr. Und er macht so eine Pappplatte nach der nächsten. Love it. Das ist, glaube ich, gar kein schlechter Film. Am Ende konnte er sich eine Sache leisten, die er am Anfang wollte. Er wollte unbedingt einen Basketballkorb oder so was, so einen sympathischen kleinen Wunsch. Von den Steuersparnissen leistete er sich einen Basketballkorb. Zum Beispiel. Aber ich glaube, das ist gar kein, weil ich meine natürlich, wir müssen natürlich auch Storytelling-technisch denken. Am Ende verliebt er sich tatsächlich, klar. Also so ein bisschen wie hier Freundschaft mit Interessen, Freundschaft mit Vorzügen, wo es halt auf dieser pragmatischen Sexebene ist, aber dann verliebt man sich. Ich glaube, in Deutschland funktioniert es eher mit pragmatischer Steuersparnesebene. Das ist eine deutsche Version, ein deutscher Romkong. Verliebt man sich aber dann trotzdem am Traualtar, also auch so ganz bürokratisch irgendwie, alle im Anzug mit Aktenkoffern steht am Altar und dann so wirklich nur wegen der Steuersparnis. Und dann so, nein, ich habe mich dann doch ein bisschen nicht verliebt. Ende aus. Ich habe mich dann doch ein bisschen nicht verliebt, ist dann der romanische Satz. Film aus. Der Film aus ist so drauf. Warum hat das nicht wirklich geschnitten? Direkt nach dem Satz. Film aus. Film aus. Auch merkwürdig. Am Set gerufen worden. Alle Komparsen drehen sich auch um. Es war auch ein merkwürdiger Dreh irgendwie. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Film an, Film aus. Film an. Film aus. Film aus. Danke. Bin nicht schlecht. Ne, sehr gut, finde ich, lass uns mal pitchen.
Lass uns mal mal ein Drehbuch schreiben.
Wir schreiben mal wieder dann ein Drehbuch, okay.
Aber ist es eine Parodie auf Rom-Com?
Ja, ja, klar.
Also so Szenen, die man kennt,
halt irgendwie dann am Flughafen,
reist noch mal hinterher zum Flughafen.
Weil sie noch ihre Esther-Bescheinigung vergessen hat,
ihm zu schicken.
Ja, genau. Sie muss noch irgendwas unterschreiben mit der Steuerprüfung oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und du hast dann einen coolen Sidekick, der halt normalerweise immer so der Kuppler ist, der so ein bisschen dafür sorgt, dass man diese persönlichen, genau, der ist der Steuerberater einfach. Und finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Und die beste Freundin von ihr irgendwie, die dann auch sagt, ja, du könntest dir halt dann schon irgendwie auch ein neues Auto leisten, irgendwie sowas. Eigentlich braucht es auch eine Figur, die eigentlich sagt, willst du dich nicht richtig verlieben? Stimmt. So eine Figur, so eine Rom-Com-Figur halt. Wer könnte das sein? Vielleicht so ein sprechender Fisch oder sowas. Oder so, dass man sagt. Nee, oder einfach ein Mensch. Ja, oder einfach. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist auch gut. Ich dachte, vielleicht hat sie so einen Fisch bei sich zu Hause. Aber ist, also, die Geschlechter kann man ja auch drehen oder wenden, wie man will. Aber ist sie dann eigentlich die totale Romantikerin, die erst überzeugt werden muss? Wie ist es denn normalerweise in Rom-Com? Eigentlich muss man sich einfach nur umdrehen. Normalerweise bei Rom-Com istS ist es so, sie treffen sich. Er will sie, sie will nicht oder umgekehrt. Sie treffen sich, verlieben sich mehr oder weniger sofort, werden dann aber durch irgendwas wieder getrennt, irgendwie erzieht in eine andere Stadt oder die Familien haben was dagegen. Oder die Gesellschaft verbietet es. Gesellschaft verbietet es und dann merken die beide, dass sie nicht mehr unter den anderen leben können. Da gibt es dann die Szenen, wie sie Dinge machen, die sie davor gemacht haben, bevor sie ihn getroffen haben, aber der Spieleabend mit den Freunden macht keinen Spaß mehr, sie hat irgendwie in ihrem Job, den sie davor geliebt hat, irgendwie nicht mehr so die Erfüllung und man merkt, ah, sie brauchen sich doch und dann muss man doch irgendwie wieder einen Weg finden, wie sie zusammenkommen, obwohl sie eigentlich schon abgeschied genommen haben und dann kommt die Flughafenszene oder die Regenszene oder was auch immer und bei uns könnte es so sein, er ist der pragmatische Typ, steuern. Eigentlich dürfte, müsste sie, vielleicht ist sie aber auch diese Kupplerfigur, dass sie nicht ... Eigentlich müssen wir das sehr pragmatisch mal aufschreiben und dann genau das Gegenteil nehmen. Also immer wo in so Quäntchenromantik auftaenden Rom-Com-Szenen müssten wir sagen, nee, maximal pragmatisch. Ihr könnt da nächste Woche ein Drehbuch von uns erwarten. Florentin wird sich hinsetzen, wenn er jetzt auch Zeit hat, mal übrigens Reden zu schreiben für irgendwelche Hochzeiten, kann er ja auch schon mal ein bisschen Drehbuch schreiben. Ich würde sagen, wir reichen das nächste Woche danach. Ja, machen wir eine Lesung von einer kleinen Szene. Eine Lesung. Nächste Woche.
Das habt ihr gerade nicht gesehen, aber Stefan hat sich mimisch den Hals durchgeschnitten.
Was machen wir?
Hacks ins Eis. Schön, Kopf
in Eis. Kopf in Eis, könnt auch ihr
stecken, wir sehen uns nächste
Woche. Kopf in Eis, bis nächste Woche.
Ich kann auch, diese Abmoderation,
das machst es mittlerweile so
sehr, ich mache es immer nach,
wie so ein Kind, was versucht zu imitieren.
Aber ich weiss, was die Wörter bedeuten.
Weil ich nicht diese Frank-Elster-Masterclass betreffe,
klatzt bei mir halt immer nicht.
Kopf in der Eis auch bei euch, nächste Woche
sehen wir uns wieder, wenn es wieder heisst
Hallo zum Podcast
UFO. Bis dahin
wünsche ich euch und der Flo dient bestimmt auch eine schöne Woche.
Ciao.